let's go next to Tiffany, Tiffany from Unknown
Location. Where are you calling from today?
South Carolina, South Carolina,
what's going on there?
They want Trump
just and they got him, didn't they?
I definitely want I'm new to all this.
I just it's a lot going on here.
A lot of conservative views. Yes.
They're definitely trying to get the
voter fraud and everything under play.
I don't know. What are your thoughts on that?
Well, my thoughts are they say let the courts
have a say. So far, everything that's been brought
to courts, courts have found to be without merit.
They say networks don't call elections. That's
always the case until the election is certified.
But Trump was glad to have networks call
it in 2016. I mean, it's it's all so far.
You know, they say in Pennsylvania, we were too
far from the ballots to observe what was going on,
but yet we were close enough to see that there
was signature fraud happening. It's like how
could both be true? But I'm curious, like
in South Carolina, are you is this a topic
of conversation? Like if you go to the corner
store or the grocery store or wherever is there
are people just saying like, yep, Joe Biden,
he just he had it stolen. He didn't really win.
Is that happening there?
Well, I mean, you may not hear it
verbatim, you know, just randomly, but
they tend to be a bit more Republican.
Yes. Yes.
No, that's a that's an understatement,
you know, but a I mean, everybody
I mean, they have their opinions. Everybody
has a right to choose. But I was just curious,
is he some people say I've heard, you know,
he's not going to get reelected. I'm saying
you just wait, wait and see. They're going down.
I know that all of these ideas of like,
could Trump do it? Is there could Trump use the
Pentagon to then use the military to stage a coup
or something like that? I just think
the answer is no. I think we shouldn't
even buy into it. Joe Biden has a transition
team. Joe Biden is a coronavirus task force.
He will be making some cabinet appointments.
I just think we're moving forward.
You know, that's a right
that he can seize right now.
Has is your family all anti Trump or
are there some Trump in your family?
No one in my family is the Democratic. My
husband, it is Republican. So we get along
really. And now there is your husband. Did your
husband vote Trump or is he a Biden Republican?
Oh, he's no, he's for Trump. Wow. And and
it's not a conflict with you for you guys.
I mean, no, he's he's no dummy.
Hey, great. Surprisingly enough.
And do you it does he say what
issues led him to vote for Trump?
Well.
I think it's just the matter of
he's always been very political and
he was a kid, so I mean, he grew up.
In is if his mom is public and his dad
kind of changed the Republicans, it's
so it's more like he's culturally conservative.
And so he just voted for Trump without really
thinking about the issues.
Right. Wow. Wow.
And I grew up more democratic.
But, you know, I tend to think I'm not
at all I don't like parties like labeling
myself. I don't know if I'm more.
I just kind of put the time,
obviously, but I am open to things.
You said you what? You said you are a Christian.
I'm open to different things. I'm not not negative
wise, but I'm not I don't I just don't view
I don't like to be labeled. Makes sure.
Yeah. Now now, was it
important to you that Joe Biden
is religious?
Oh.
My view points, I believe in morals and
values, but I also believe in justice and
the way things, and I just always felt there
is going to be sort of equality there with
all these different rights. I do. I hear
different viewpoints and they're saying
this is going to happen since he's been elected.
And I haven't seen the right the first. I don't
know if that's some coincidence.
Yes, that is interesting for sure.
Well, what we'll see very well, it sounds like I
mean, listen, you're making it work with a Trump
supporter. I think that that's very interesting.
OK, Stephanie, thank you so much for the call.
All right. All right. Take care. Tiffany married
to a Trump supporter. Wow. Let's go next to.
Where are we going? Let's let's go to hold
on where we have so many people popping up.